One of the things we've been following since the
January 6th Trump riots has been the involvement
of law enforcement and or military in the riots.
And we now are starting to see numbers attached
to this that are not particularly reassuring
about the US military. Active military personnel
and veterans are overrepresented. Looking at the
first 150 arrests and records released about what
took place on January 6th, CNN did an analysis
of Pentagon records and court proceedings and
found that 14 percent of the first 150 arrests
are of current or former members of the U.S.
military. That's more than doubled the proportion
of servicemen and women in the population. That's
calculated based on Census Bureau and Department
of Defense Statistics. Back in 2013, there were
one point three million active duty members of the
services and 18 million veterans together. That's
five point nine percent of the population. And yet
14 percent of those arrested are members, current
or former of some branch of the U.S. military.
Two of those are army to our National Guard. Of
the seventeen veterans, six are former Army aide
or former Marines, two are former Navy. One was
in the Air Force, at least one served in Vietnam.
Others tended to be deployed to Afghanistan and
Iraq, which makes sense from the standpoint
of age. At least one earned a Purple Heart
discharged at a variety of ranks and included
officers as well, a captain and a lieutenant
colonel. So there's a few different issues here.
First of all, just from like a very abstract
historical standpoint, if you're
at all familiar with Roman history,
there's sort of like a classic Roman historical
idea of disgruntled soldiers supporting
their leader, their emperor, for a coup attempt.
And so I don't know that we need to go the
whole sort of sort of poetic route with this or
historical analogies. But they are certainly there
and it's not an unprecedented thing. One question
I have is this particular study from Pentagon data
done by CNN is military, current and former. If we
were to say military and law enforcement, I wonder
where the number goes to from 14 percent. That's
that's one question. But this is a well known
sort of historical element that that
repeats itself. And to be very clear,
this isn't about saying troops are bad as
people in principle there are. I mean, listen,
you can even say that these are victims, right?
If you understand the idea that there is a massive
adaptation problem for people post military
service, this seems to be more of a vulnerability.
When we talk to I mean, I'm not making an analogy
here between white supremacists and former members
of the military. But what I do think is important
to understand is that after traumatic experiences
or during them, people become vulnerable to
really bad ideas and to be sucked in by cults.
And every former white supremacist we've talked
to, every former KKK person we've talked to
has told us essentially the same story about they
were in a vulnerable place. And just as they fell
for the community granted to them by the ideas of
white supremacy, because that's what was going on
around them, they could have been pulled in by
a religion. They could have been pulled in by by
almost anything. And we know that there are lots
of folks who serve in the military and they have
a difficulty adapting to post military life.
And you could fall into any number of different
things. So this is not about simply saying
that the people are bad people necessarily,
but there might be some explanation here as
to why the Trampas thought that if they do the
insurrection and they try to steal the election
for Trump, that maybe the military would stand
down. Is it possible because. They themselves,
as members of the military, current or former,
thought that maybe that's something that
would happen, that maybe the military
would join them in the insurrection. I don't
know. I'm thinking out loud here, but the numbers
are certainly stunning, you know, more than a
2x representation relative to the population
of current and former military. And I don't I
mean, you tell me whether this is too cynical.
Is it conceivable that they may have been targeted
on social media? I mean, we know at this point
the degree to which campaigns can be targeted to
folks so narrowly on social media. Is it possible?